you're a bird let's get you out of here  library  we've got room and you still need a ride  still have unfinished business here sir  we'll make it down to the ring though  we'll see that you keep this far  godspeed  [Applause]  we have to make sure  [Applause]  hostile reinforcements inbound  he sounds  unpleasant  taking him down would buy the unsc more  time on this ring what do you think  more of them chief  he sounds  unpleasant  taking him down would buy the unsc more  time on this ring what do you think  i'm picking up reinforcements coming our  way  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  that's a wrap on the target let's clean  up the rest of them  that's the end of zeratus the scourge  maker  may his stupid nickname die with him